all right how many parents out there
struggle with math you know it raise
your hand so what happens when your kids
come to you for help well in today's 8
on your side we've got another tool to
add to your arsenal that brings other
students into the
equation as a parent it is
i mean just a fantastic tool to have
because i'm terrible at math patrick
quinn's 12 and 15 year olds know where
to go when they need help with math
brainly.com a free online study group
where fellow students not adults are
helping them find the solution a great
way for kids to learn from other kids at
their level rather than just
us adults kind of just trying to teach
out to them brainly started in poland
with more than 350 million users a month
it's growing here in the united states
anytime you have a problem you type in
your question and it could be a student
in prague or anywhere around the globe
who jumps on to help you most kids join
when they're when they're struggling
with something yeah but then once they
start using it they start
helping the other kids and that really
just reinforces the learning that they
are already good at so it just like like
strengthens it in one direction and also
in the other direction there are
multiple levels of monitoring to make
sure answers are correct as well as
content experts and artificial
intelligence to protect the interactions
as well it's a great community where the
kids sort of police themselves they love
it and they kind of protect it
and a recent poll conducted by brainly
found that nevada ranked 42nd which was
considered high on the end of needing
homework health students in
massachusetts needed the least help with
homework and the state that needed the
most homework help louisiana